[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about whatever we want [ __ ] face
what do you want to talk about joe man
i've been saying like isn't it crazy how
like if you're a part of the comedy
world and kind of hollywood and
mainstream you have to be a certain way
you have to think a certain way you have
to
make jokes like that are more
once like on representative of the kind
of sjw world yeah it's crazy you play
devil's advocate i do think you know in
comedy you have to read the room right
but if your room gets bigger
you're reading a different room so they
might be actually be considered being a
their comedy might be sucking but they
might be becoming a better comedian what
depends because like ellen will still go
for it pretty hard she will no
what happened with her show
like tell me about the joke
when has she gone crazy is she still in
the air or she she's done so there's no
more ellen show she's done she's done i
mean she gave it up she got a lot of
heat first of all she got canceled the
cancer got canceled yeah yeah yeah and
then she got cancelled because everyone
was coming out like she's a bitch-ass
boss i had friends that worked on that
shot they're like oh yeah she is that
crazy wow oh really but like but that's
also how she got successful because
she's not crazy
crazy people do crazy things yeah
she don't got a show no more no no she
gave it up
i just thought she was putting youtubers
and tick talkers on the map [ __ ]
landing for for soccer moms to enjoy
yeah mike song went on there like three
times but i think the work culture got
her cancelled right because she's
supposed to like be super hard to work
for or something yeah like that was like
what the allegations that she went like
she had asked people not to make eye
contact with her
and her explanation of that was like oh
it's more like i just get nervous around
people i'm like
what a [ __ ] talk show
you make eye contact you're a stand-up
comedian bro you were [ __ ] looking my
eyes i just get nervous was it people
that was like whatever but like
but i think it's a way because she
presents herself a certain way on tv but
it's someone else she doesn't keep it
across she doesn't keep it the same
energy across it is that
unfair
excuse me are you are you gonna go are
you gonna be a counter culture guy right
now yeah dude i wouldn't do it here pal
this is not a safe place for you [ __ ]
don't walk into that film cause some
people are notorious for crazy [ __ ] but
that's also what gets them
places like we have a friend that's an
actor and he worked with a really famous
hong kong director
and he got slapped like five times in
the face before his scene
and that's he said like at first he
wanted to kick his ass but then that
really got him to kill the scene so he
had like he's like literally this guy
it's like when he's shooting a movie
like the hong kong way it's money over
art right at least the way this guy
shoots so
if the scene was his brother just died
he finds out he runs into the bathroom
in this new york apartment and he just
starts bawling out
so he tells him okay i might need like
maybe an hour to prep for this
and then the director is like no you got
five minutes because right after this
and we're moving on we gotta shoot
something else and then he's like i
can't do it in five minutes he goes are
you [ __ ] professional he said he
slapped his face and goes do it in ten
minutes he slapped him like five times
and he wanted to fight him but then
somehow that riled up the emotions and
he actually did the scene and he killed
it and he did it in one take and did he
thank the director
no but then he was like but then in
retrospect he was like
oh [ __ ] like this director's like
notoriety
does actually get the job done kubrick
did that to show you along on the set of
the shining he was like calling her a
[ __ ] and stuff
she's like
to get her to cry like and it was
working she was crying her eyes out she
did a great job in that movie yeah yeah
solid but i'd argue that that's very
that's very different than saying to
your staff like don't look at me in the
eyes that's crazy yeah yeah there's no
actual result that comes yeah what's the
point of you saying that just because
you have anxieties yeah because you're
not like getting a certain action or
product out of yeah what's more likely
that you have anxiety or you're just
kind of a [ __ ]
you think that if you reach a certain
level though right you get to have like
a writer and you get to like tell people
like what you want when you show up and
[ __ ] sure and you know you get to ellen
level don't you start to just try to see
if they'll do it
he did what else can i put on the list
are they gonna [ __ ] do this [ __ ]
maybe uh uh tech rider was only blue m
ms in a bowl i know that
i knew that diddies yeah so they have to
buy bags of m ms and only [ __ ] put
blue ones he doesn't want to see unpaid
intern oh yeah exactly yeah it's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] bro
that's [ __ ] crazy wouldn't you do
that just to see if they'll [ __ ] do
it not for something like that i would
do it to see how thorough they are yeah
yeah there you go because it's i mean
not
continuously that's abusive but if
they're new i would do random things
like that to see
beyond their resume if they can perform
such as
not like the blue m m thing right so it
makes sense it's like
okay
uh
they're gonna be in the future
going through things where if they make
a mistake money is on the line or
whatever let me do something that's not
so consequential like if they do mess up
but i can test how thorough and good
they could be i want a big titty lady to
make me a button milkshake yes what's up
yeah what's up
i don't know what it is but yes you have
to figure it out
i like it
that [ __ ] better come with cookies and
cream and buttons that are edible poor
kid bro he's going to be able to drink
it by the way i'm not talking about big
titty i'm talking about big titties
what does that mean an underline in the
contract writer
big titty lady the random entertaining
[ __ ] i don't even i don't know i don't
think i have that in me
yeah i don't like making people feel
like dude i had a boss
just so she can um
kind of like show
her dominance on me um she was like
telling her staff watch this right i was
new i didn't know what to do so she's
like hey joe can you go get me a
uh ice cream and i was like thinking oh
that's probably for one of the tables
over there and then i was like uh what
do you want whatever okay cool i went
and scooped up the ice cream i gave it
to her and she goes thanks and she's
eating it in front of me and they're
laughing and i'm like okay [ __ ] what's
up
uh i can't really defy her can't slap
her in the face
and um i waited till things were
extremely busy
and i was like can i do something to
help you she goes oh thank god all right
can you do this and this this and i'm
like all right
and then i waited and waited and waited
and watched her suffer and i do jack
[ __ ]
and then i got fired
you know why she's not the only manager
there there's three other managers and i
was in great favors with them and on top
of that i told on her when she got drunk
on the job and she got fired whoa
don't [ __ ] with me you are petty
hey but don't be drinking on the job
like that you know what i mean like you
you [ __ ] yourself up yeah yeah she
[ __ ] yourself up yeah
in that same place i also pushed the
manager in the kitchen and it was pretty
funny you're petty
and in that same time he fell on the
knives and died
because he i think jonathan
exists in the middle area that's true i
guess that works yeah yeah you just run
hospital joe though that's old joe then
i burned the restaurant
that restaurant actually burned down bro
it did burn down yeah it was me
it did burn down though yeah it's not
there anymore well it burned down it's
gone it still is still a question how do
you think burning works well i don't
know if i thought that we built it or
something like insurance money rebuilt
them just fire
with that restaurant people did
speculate that it was insurance fraud
right there is something especially if
it's chinese owned that's what they're
known for it was right across the street
from my job my whole job yeah
wow i know killed somebody in there yep
crazy
statute of limitations is what seven
years or something i'll talk about it in
three more years
no it was pretty interesting i guess i
can't be petty what a great way to find
that out yeah old stories bring it out
of you have you guys done that as like a
position of leadership in your companies
or wherever where it's like you like the
kind of the writer thing have you been
like wanted to test out like when this
person picked me up i don't know like
that big titty lady with the [ __ ]
motion have you tried anything like that
no does anyone try anything like that on
you at the even in the military like a
hazing thing oh the military happens
like all the time like my old boss would
always be like he's doing his
inspections and [ __ ] like let's say
there's trash like hey quan
don't forget to pick that up
and i'm like halfway down and i'm like
[ __ ] you could just pick that up
but i have to run over there yeah and
pick it up and just like stuff like that
it's like but it's all part of also
half hazing half building character i
guess yeah i think i think when it goes
into like the company culture or culture
in general of an organization like there
is like a hazing element but i feel like
the concept of hazing means there's a
usually a reward in some way like you're
supposed to okay or you know
get something from it right whether it's
like a a momentary thing or a position
or something you know what i'm saying so
yeah we do that sometimes but like
there's clearly reward yeah like in in a
certain tough kind of things right you
got to like in the military right you
got to test a person's
like mental strength or whatever push
their buttons to see if they're down or
not or if they're a [ __ ] and if that's
someone you want to take to the next
level with you i think the difference of
abusing your power and when it comes
abusive is when you're doing it for your
own entertainment and you don't see
like kind of like in karate kid right
there are scenes of like mr miyagi tell
them to do [ __ ] chores and doing all
this free work painting your [ __ ] when
am i going to [ __ ] learn real karate
wax on [ __ ] pie and he's like ha right
and it's like oh [ __ ] all along it was
for me
but you do have people in power that are
just straight dick faces
and they they [ __ ] with you
because they think it's funny and then
that's it there's no benefit for you
yogi just got on the penis fence and
stuff let's be real that's true
i mean bro what up guys this episode is
brought to you by neutral
did you know that there are over 80
million americans men and women that
experience thinning in the hair happens
a lot it's pretty common it's okay but
the thing is if you don't want that to
happen you can't just let that happen to
you you have to take control of it and
that's why i like nutrifoal because it's
a supplement that you can take and it's
organic it's drug free it's something
that you can take to help increase the
health of your hair your skin and your
nails on top of that it's really cool
because you get thicker stronger hair
without chemicals or lasers and like
bart said it's a hundred percent drug
free they sent me a trial and i was like
bro
i grew this
all by myself but i am curious because
it's drug-free i want to see
how healthier my hair can be because i
don't do much care to this i just kind
of like
homeless style myself i just go into the
wild like a jungle man and then i get a
little bit of you know water that falls
on the trees and then i use that in the
shower
so
what would happen if i could maximize
like this full potential of the hair and
this is probably one of the best
alternatives i'm gonna have i'm gonna
try this for the next three to six
months and see
how it can affect my hair in a different
way in clinical trials 72 percent of
males
saw more scalp coverage uh when taking
neutrophil and also 86
females
got improved hair growth after using it
for six months wow so i do think it's
going to make your hair stronger thicker
and better so if that's something you
guys are interested in make sure you go
check it out
nutrafull.com and use the promo code otr
and it's spelled n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l
use the promo code otr to get 15 off
your first month and that's the best
deal you're gonna find anywhere and it's
limited to the us customers only
neutralfold.com used the promo code otr
who benefited more mr bianchi or daniel
yeah
what does that even block bro yeah how
does that block you watch it hit me dude
see look oh [ __ ] oh
that kind of did work actually better
than i thought it was better than i it
wasn't great but it was better than i
thought
which is right above worse
and nick is a trained fighter so against
a trained fighter uh blacks on wax off
works way better i was really trying to
hit you too my [ __ ] home depot skills
came in handy dude dude this guy's
kidding [ __ ] what a construction worker
dude they just know kung fu all the time
that's where kung fu was created all
kinds of [ __ ] physical labor
[Laughter]
we always find a way to bring it back to
dicks don't worry yes that's happening
it's a talent bro it's it's it's called
the jackie chan
jackie but yes yeah that was actually
pretty good
the what this is
you remember when he was saying jacket
on jacket off we were cracking up in the
theater in tears i don't remember that
but i'm going to rewatch it
yeah yeah yeah that point oh jack it up
jack it up jack it off
oh [ __ ] i get it that's great that [ __ ]
was great love it check it off check it
out jackie chan's as a joke that was
actually a really good remake the only
weird thing about it was called karate
kid and they were clearly doing concrete
kung fu kids it was like shaolin should
have been gongfu
g-o-n-g the gongfu kid
what's your all-time favorite like kung
fu rush hour three
what that's the best one because they're
friends i know what everyone knows
that's the best one you know what's the
underrated american action film is a
black sport no that's not underrated
yeah that's overrated
what no i mean it's just rated how do i
say it's good it's highly rated it's
highly rich it's worth it one of my
favorites saying high noon is fine
shanghai noon is very very good it is
it's on amazon prime it's so much better
it's crazy yeah so much better we all i
did like what's the difference shanghai
nights in shanghai new york is terrible
i don't know that they were swinging on
big ben [ __ ] the second one
yeah exactly they killed a guy with a
firework hey if you were following the
improv pattern shanghai noon shanghai
nights what's the third one
oh i don't even know shanghai wait noon
and then night shanghai breakfast
i think we're going backwards with that
one guys
night like night time or nights in
shining armor
they're in london so they're dressed
like that oh shanghai and then was it a
play on words because like noon and
night night oh so what are they missing
they're missing shanghai well nice was
spelled with a k so they're like nights
like medieval nights
how about shanghai samurai
shanghai zulu warrior this isn't teenage
mutant ninja turtles three man he's like
i learned a different brand of improv
that doesn't connect that way
thanks a lot eugene cordero yeah wow
shots fired jesus shanghai vegas
i don't think he gets it they they all
moved to vegas for lower taxes
for a tax break they moved to the
shanghover part three
oh
you're fired from my writer from dude
[Laughter]
oh my gosh
that's the sequel oh there it is shane
you're excited for shank sheet gilbert
like that like there's much smurf like
that yeah it's not real can't stop
talking about it man every time we see
him come on
[Laughter]
no we just walked right by each other
you didn't say hi then well i'm just you
know i'm just some guy did you remember
one time he was uh yoshi trained him and
then she would punch his girlfriend in
the face
[Laughter]
hey man you know you did it bro if
you're watching this
punched yoshi's girlfriend in the middle
i know the hell
i think the story is yoshi was training
with his girlfriend at the time yeah and
like she was getting really hit but just
saw this
she was supposed to weep she didn't even
his own girlfriend on his face holy [ __ ]
it's gonna be our next shark this is a
whole lie guys i'm sorry okay
see who beat up his girlfriend
we need we need this to do well for
asian americans we are not going to get
him
missing no [ __ ] this
he did not punch her it happened she was
supposed to she was they were doing a
drill the story don't work he didn't
punch her she had bad d okay but it was
and off anything it was her fault if
next shark gets a hold of this they're
gonna twist his ass shane cheap punches
girlfriend
with ten rings
free promotion yeah dog we have more
eyes back in the writer's room what's up
yeah
you were always in
you've never left don't you excited for
it for the main reason the action
because brad allen the who i i just
r.i.p bro i just passed away i just
passed away and he was actually that was
his last project was it
that's why it looks so good that's
jackie chan's protege white protege wow
he went white i'm very excited to see
what they do with marble and actual like
good choreography if they shoot it right
damn
it looked pretty good and one of the one
of the fights in the trailer looked
pretty good it kind of looks like a
regular asian movie huh it kind of does
very hong kong style it looks like all
asian i mean asian pitch perfect
15 years right they just speak english
and aquafina's a marvel title in front
of
them
you're right i like that part yeah i
like it
it looks like a regular asian movie
all your movies
and once they once they figured out like
cg and stuff like 20 years ago man
always they went crazy right yeah in all
the asian films
especially india like you said i love
indian films the best a genre of its own
i saw this one scene where this guy he
was he had a girl hostage and then uh
this cop [ __ ]
took his motorcycle and then everyone
was on the pier it was a long period oh
yeah this is the best one [ __ ] hit
this uh ramp he passed over everybody
and threw the [ __ ] motorcycle at the
bad guy and saved the girl on his feet
landed on it
he's like superman bro this sounds like
vin diesel and fast and furious
way more over the top
it's like a mile dude this is the
biggest [ __ ] pier i've ever seen
evil knievel wished he could hop over
[ __ ] 300 how do we write a movie like
that we need to write movies like that
it's very expensive yeah that's true bro
there's one a lot of cg that's true i
saw this one where a girl was like i
don't know she got slapped or something
and then she fell and then got wrapped
up in a curtain and then the curtain
[ __ ] made her into a ball and then
that ball fell into a suitcase and the
suitcase got closed
and the bell boy took the suitcase
thinking it was hotel luggage and then
it went into a van and it [ __ ]
disappeared
and then they lost her damn yeah
they know how to do movies
they know something have you seen doom
have you seen that one my dad loves that
one wait the dwayne johnson no no
the bollywood movie
it's just an action movie with dancing
johnson who says that right nobody yeah
i was like yeah why are you bringing up
that movie
i forgot he made that one
was he really in there yes
he was the bad guy in the movie he got
killed if he was in it they did like
at the end they did a part where there's
like pov like the doom guy with like the
gun
he was pre uh instagram the rock yeah i
think he blew up like crazy because of
social media it was when he only it was
before he started making really bad
movies did he do fast and furious then
no no not the reign of scorpion king oh
yeah it's quality stuff you know that
movie was bomb though huh that was the
best one yeah that was super good i
loved it better than the mummies oh you
guys seen uh brenton frasier as of
recently yeah
that's why i said okay you're gonna be
shocked at what he looks like is he like
super buff and sexy now is he for a roll
dude is he doing it for real no this is
him he
hired nick the ear workout training
program so he looks like [ __ ] is all
right
ads loading lots of apps go to the
images hey nick you've been training
people yeah
always baby that's right now holy [ __ ]
where
that's exactly definitely like a thumb
he looks like peter griffin bro
what the [ __ ] happened do you remember
sexy brendon frazier from the mommy yeah
he was jack
damn he was a stud what about tarzan or
whatever the [ __ ] what are you
oh that's right we're journeying to the
center of the earth or whatever wow he
kind of looks like a hollywood exec now
he looks like russell crow now yeah he
looks kind of like uh harvey weinstein a
little bit he looks good in superman no
i think russell crawls always this is
crazy like look at this that was him
that's how i remember my bread and
fraser he's a real piece you know all he
loves jews he looks like a normal guy
like like a guy that was playing
football in high school and then now
he's a dad that's what he looks like he
looks american
he did play the same role huh because he
did he didn't see no man and he did
george the jungle and that's kind of the
same guy right and ceno man was very
good that's crazy
i think it was polly short's best movie
he's actually hiring an assistant i
don't know if i could work out there you
should dude he's a great guy he was on
this show he was the best yeah he was so
awesome was it cool asians doing here
bruh asians bruh isn't the part asian i
think so he calls bobby a chinese baby
all the time oh cool in public
perfect
of our most favorite [ __ ] guests ever
on jk news dude
[Music]
you